the committee has meticulously presented
a narrative charting donald trump's
refusal to accept the presidential
election results of 2020. they argue
that he began a campaign targeting state
elections officials then the department
of justice and then vice president mike
pence in previous hearings several
senior figures in trump's circle have
testified that there was no case to be
made the election was free and fair and
on tuesday the committee played
testimony from the white house legal
council explaining he felt the same way
at some point you have to put up or shut
up
and right now once legal challenges had
been exhausted and the electoral college
met on december the 14th to certified
joe biden was the president-elect trump
held what was described as an unhinged
meeting on the 18th pitting white house
staff against trump's informal set of
advisers who were advocating seizing
voting machines for example
what they were proposing
i thought was nuts
i'm gonna categorically describe it
as you guys are not tough enough
unhappy with his options the committee
argues that's when trump decided to
quote summon the mob with a tweet in the
early hours of the 19th of december
trump sent out the tweet
with his explosive invitation
trump repeated his big lie and claimed
it was quote statistically impossible to
have lost the 2020 election
before calling for a big protest in dc
on january 6th
be there
will be wild
the tweet mobilized right-wing
paramilitary groups like the proud boys
and the oath keepers now they had a date
to focus on as they attempted to
overturn the election according to the
committee one former official and the
oath keepers who did not take part in
the riot said there was the potential
for even worse outcomes
i think we need to quit mincing words
and just talk about truths and
what it was going to be was
an armed revolution but the tweet also
mobilized rank and file trump supporters
who had no affiliation to any group
the committee did not present any
evidence that trump actively coordinated
the rat but the committee members keep
on suggesting that there was a
convergence of interests next week's
hearing will be about trump's reaction
to the right and the growing fears of
those around him in addition committee
members announced that they'd seen what
they felt was more evidence of donald
trump attempting to tamper with
witnesses to the committee shia britancy
al jazeera capitol hill